hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's now I am going to attempt to
beat this game right now and I have a
strategy to do it now I have kind of
figured this out already but you don't
actually need to watch where they are
throughout the entire building
considering that they can just jump
behind your door at any time so the most
important thing to do is this check
outside your door with the lights and
check on Pirates Cove very frequently
because this [ __ ] over here it
doesn't even know what he's doing so how
is he gonna give me advice when he's
already stuffed into a freaking box
[Music]
hi balls no no no oh yeah
no no no no no no no you do nothing okay
so god damn it it's like I forget how
bad it is and then I get in here and
then it's just horrifying
so either way so I got a pretty solid
strategy to go about this cuz it doesn't
even matter when my time spent finding
him is just time wasting power why my
spy oh I don't do that to me Tom as well
just spend my resources very quickly
checking frequently distributing
everything was seen very closely to the
random noises that are playing in my ear
and not worrying about anything thinking
about like bunny rabbits or something
[Music]
I'm checking a little too frequently but
I want to just be very careful here
because if one of them does end up
popping out behind my door I need to
know about it okay so
all right you sons a [ __ ] word I'm
settled in for a long night don't even
think that you're gonna sneak up on me
why do I have to go through six hours
and s crap why did I come back for
another night it's not like I signed a
Blood Pact to come back here every
single night it's like four bucks an
hour people actually worked out I'm here
tonight for four bucks an hour I'm
watching bad okay
that's guys down watch fire Cove what's
that for ducky wait till he's gone okay
okay he's still there okay hold on Zach
still there good good good at least I
have company for my nightmare good yeah
I feel choked up spit hippie out already
I gotta keep a closer eye on him he
can't be out already laughs dear
oh I barely even missed him oh I gotta
hear ye forget it do I even get to hear
footsteps before they get here
yeah yeah no no this is keys all right
it's okay but I'm gonna use to it it
ain't so bad anymore except that it's
horri [ __ ] no no no no no you can't be
sneaking out there right now I've got my
eye on you so hard no no no Who am I
supposed to check you how often am I
supposed to check him no oh I gotta be
even more classic Sevilla if I see you
even for a goddamn second on it their
flavor that door down so quickly
someone's in the kitchen no don't even
think about it this is my pattern
there's my pattern for the end of days
yeah pirate old man tired Eman whatever
he is I don't even know I think he's
coyote but I'm not entirely sure but I
don't want to know anymore because I
want to just get through this night and
spa to get through this night
having lights on it's my pattern so my
days are done
it's got to make sure hire Cole man
evenly for a goddamn second I'm gonna
lose my goddamn I'd owe you dummy are
you gonna be say you gonna be with this
dumbass game
god I really don't know what everything
oh my god where they out whatever Oh God
what would I do now do you go away
what is that Oh what is that my music
way too much power I think this one open
is he gonna come back
he's gonna kill a Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I couldn't shake my Rico war I hate that
I hate this game I hate it I hate it I
hate it so goddamn much don't even
understand gotta beat it though [ __ ]
here we go
no no no who's the gentleman
Oh goddammit were you out I'm singing so
much
so apparently mr. fuzzy Lumpkins likes
to hang outside the door right towards
the end of the night and kill me dead I
don't appreciate that
god damn why is the night so goddamn
long don't much care for you don't
appreciate who do that don't do the fast
steps on me god I can't take the fast
steps no fuzzy bear if you're freaking
there I'm gonna kill you I stuff in you
out of your suit as soon as he leaves oh
I gotta be ready to roll
reaction so fast like Mongoose weird
weird do that Master Joe generally
though you're so weird not freaked out
here very calmly
now rescue that one son of a [ __ ] okay
fine Singh still there oh he's still
there he is so there boy come about that
you give me the door and murdered me oh
wait boss giving him such piss-poor
choices about life
oh I am NOT gonna have enough power I'm
so not having enough power now he's
still there oh he's still there you
still there okay okay okay they're still
there he's gone hey he's back a fire
cuff okay
oh I am so done oh dude thank you dude
out literally nothing you know
I'm so close
[Music]
oh boy is it this is it guys this is the
fifth I can make it I can make it even
pirate cause not that bad I don't need
to check him that off and if he resets
that's not even the big of issue you're
dead you're dead man
you're so dead
[Music]
okay so I can be a little bit more
conservative about checking especially
pirate Cove because he'll reset if I
catch him in time not to kill me all I
need to do is check it periodically
he'll be side nothing-- coal burner my
brains out then they need to watch the
doors outside
[Music]
I'll be fine I'm gonna be totally fine
calm and collected I'm literally
sweating right now
no no no no they're doing their friend
are you doing their weirdo friend new
dum-dum [ __ ] you go away any candy for
you mister trick-or-treater I just fine
gonna be fine cuz I know the rules
I know how to play the game I understand
now
da dum dum dum da dum dum dum do you
understand that dum dum just a whole lot
of this huh doing okay okay doing okay I
got the rules pretty much down pat don't
think much can surprise me now okay hi
are you doing over there still there
waiting on you now oh wait you're not
there anymore oh you are there there
just miss your quack attack money are
you going it's cold
all right cold man not coming out he's a
little bit shy this time around
hello okay good okay
okay he's still there but I'm doing okay
I think I actually got this I'm more
than look back back back he's there
so he's about to pop up god dammit go
away go away your ducky bastard you
didn't bother me any other time why are
you bothering me now anymore
nothing
he's not there it's all in my mind
you're still there cuz you're not in my
mind you're probably gonna kill me soon
but hey it's gonna be okay for me I'm so
dead I'm gonna run out of power at this
point if you don't go up thank goodness
oh I gotta keep the door down now
because Lizzie's gonna come by
Lisa's very cold man's I bother with my
right door today
dum-dum-dum
you're a da da dum dum you're a dummy
dumb dumb dumb dumb god I'm gonna run
out of time at 33% it's only 3:00 am I
am flubber next I'm not gonna make it
can I can I open that door can I just
not cellphone so long was it pound if I
open that door I'm dead
I'm literally dead I'm gonna have to
check my camera anymore cuz I know I'm
dead do you let me open a goddamn
oh good I guess the door okay oh god I
gotta close the door I don't even know
if that's the true rule thank you both
doors close is coming kill me because
this game is rigged against me and I
hate my life
Ruby my pants didn't even make it to
5:00 a.m. I really don't even know if I
have to call his editor you know what
I'm gonna test something I'm not opening
come on baby bro
Ron what are you God open up the
floodgates come on bring it on
don't please
[Music]
I'm gonna guess then I'm not supposed to
keep the door down when he's there cuz
that wastes too much power there's no
way it can be the if if I'm if I got the
door down the entire goddamn time that
he's there I'd be screwed
[Music]
really sorry if this may seem boring to
some people but goddamn I really got
nothing else to say and I want to beat
this so bad so I'm just gonna focus on
this until it's done go say what is that
no no no no no no no no oh god damn it
okay
I don't know what to do with you I do
not know what to do about you
pretty sure I'm okay change out
Clockwerk now like clockwork orange'
I'm gonna make it I'm gonna make it this
time definitely mine maybe die from fire
Cove Joe come on oh are you gonna be
like this
[ __ ] damn you
so little longer come on
sir you're sick you're a girl you [ __ ]
how many dozen seconds oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
we would first what is that star why is
there a safe thing why it's five nights
at freddy's well guess what that's just
gonna have to wait for another episode
because I literally couldn't have cut
that last night closer than I did so I'm
lucky enough to have won it when I did
I'm very happy and I will save whatever
the hell is in the 6th night for another
episode you're just gonna have to wait
on that one till I can play it again
video way oh my god this is easily
easily the scariest game I've ever
played but unfortunately after a while
if you playing it for like a few hours
it does grow a little old on ya but it's
amazing how the tension is still there
it's a fantastic horror game it plays on
every one of your paranoid delusions
paranoia not paranoid but either way
it's so good oh I don't know how they're
gonna expand on the concept but either
way they are awesome whoever made the
scott cawthon you're awesome
so thank you all so much for watching
prepare for the 6th night later on and I
hope you all enjoyed this so far thank
you all so much for watching and as
always in the
[Music]
your mama baby laboratory happened
indicate the influent a very elaborate
lie on my throat or right Apple you will
be made like you to memory over though
for you the joy of cream
[Music]